So I'm going to briefly review some of what I told you last time and then I'm
going to walk through,
as I mentioned,
I'm going to walk through the Disney Film Pinocchio and which I presume most of
you have seen.
How many have you seen it?
Yeah.
Okay.
That's,
that's so as I think I mentioned,
that's something in and of itself,
right?
I mean,
the fact that you've all seen it means that it's an production of cultural
significance and because it's such a strange artifact,
that's one way of looking at it.
It might be worth trying to take it apart to understand why it is,
for example,
that you even understand it.
And so I offered you the proposition last week that we view the world
essentially through a narrative lens.
And I believe that we view the world through a narrative lens because of the
fundamental problem that we have to solve as living creatures is how we should
act in the world.
And that means how we should act to maintain ourselves,
but also how we need to act in relationship to other people and in relationship
to the broader world.
In order to maintain ourselves across time.
So that's a complicated problem,
right?
It's not just how you survive,
it's how you survive now and next week and next month and next year and 50 years
from now and maybe your,
your,
uh,
your descendants as well if the culture is going to stabilize and then not only
you across all those timeframes but you and everyone else across all those
timeframes to viciously difficult problem.
And so I would say that we have evolved mechanisms to solve that.
Um,
I think that's self evident in some sense because for example,
one of the mechanisms that animals have evolved to deal with the problem of
social being,
even if they're not particularly social animals,
is the dominance hierarchy.
Right?
Or You could call it a hierarchy of authority or power.
Because I think considering human structures,
social structures as mirror power structures is a terrible mistake.
It's a terrible oversimplification
because power is by no means the only like force is what I mean.
Force is not a stable way of solving the problem of how to live together across
time.
The question is what is the stable way of solving how to live together across
time?
And that really is the question and it's part of the question that I'm trying to
answer partly because it's a perennial problem,
right?
We,
we faced the problem of how to organize ourselves in small social units without
undue conflict.
And then we faced the larger problem of how to organize ourselves into large
social units without undue conflict.
And that conflict can be absolutely devastating and,
and,
and frequently is so.
So then I would also say that the first way of solving this problem isn't
conscious.
You say not at all.
And you know,
you may know and you may not know that there are,
there are different forms of memory,
right?
Really technically different forms of memory.
So for example,
there's short term working memory,
which is the memory that you use to hold things like telephone numbers in your
act of imagination.
It decays very rapidly.
It's only about four to seven bits,
which is why,
well,
it's white phone numbers or were at least seven digits long.
You know,
you can kind of manage that as a loop.
That,
and then there's um,
episodic memory and that has two elements.
One is semantic and the other is a episodic.
It's a help.
What's the name of that?
Someone said something?
Yes.
Well there's procedural memory and then there's,
there's another,
the kind of memory that you use to represent your experiences to yourself.
So let's say it's image Laden and the other one is semantic and semantic is your
memory for facts.
And those are quite different.
So for example,
procedural memory,
that's how you ride a bike.
That's how you play the piano.
That's how you play jazz music.
If you're in a combo,
it's,
it's the memory.
It's,
it's,
it's a funny kind of memory cause it's actually built right into you.
You know,
I mean so as so as the kind of memory that used to represent your life,
but it's much more malleable in some sense.
So what that means is that in your procedures,
there is information that you don't know about pattern information that you
don't know about.
Part of that is how to act.
You know,
like when you walk into a social gathering,
you don't really think through how you're going to act.
You,
you know how to act and if someone asked you exactly what it is that you're
doing and why you could formulate a story about it,
but the probability that that it's the existence of that story that enabled you
to act that way as zero because you have to react way faster than that.
And so,
you know,
you have social knowledge built into your nervous system because you've
practiced being a social being for a very long period of time.
And of course then that social being has been shaped for forever really.
And it's the right way of thinking about it.
You know,
we know that animals organize themselves into hierarchies and we'll say of
dominance because it's more,
more true the farther back you go in time,
at least since the time of the crustaceans.
You know,
when we split from our common ancestor 300 million years ago.
And so,
and it's true for social animals and non social animals.
So even animals that don't live together in groups have to organize themselves
into a hierarchy in the space they inhabit.
Songbirds are a good example.
And they have dominance disputes all the time.
Partly that's,
you can hear them having their little dominance disputes in the spring when
they're singing because basically what they're singing is I'm pretty damn
healthy and I'm ready to go.
And if you're another bird like me,
you better steer clear this tree.
And,
and the,
the dominant song birds,
you know,
they don't live together crozer social,
but most songbirds aren't.
The dominant songbirds get the best nest and the best nest is the one that
doesn't get rained on isn't,
it's not too windy and it's close to food sources and you know,
and so then they have the healthiest chicks and they attract the best mates.
And like it's really important where you're positioned in the hierarchy,
even if you're not like a flock or herd creature.
Now we're more like herd creatures.
So it's even more,
it's even,
it's even more relevant to us,
but there's just no escaping a hierarchical arrangement in social being that is
social being.
And,
and,
and it's evolutionarily ancient beyond conception.
So 300 million years ago there weren't trees,
you know,
I mean,
so the dominance hierarchy is older than trees.
So that's really something to think about.
And then you know,
when you're thinking about the reality that shaped us say from an evolutionary
perspective,
but also from a cultural perspective,
what you have to understand is that the things that have shaped us most are the
things that have been around the longest.
And so you could say those are the most real things and you can't even see some
of them.
Like it's not like you can come in here.
Well it's not exactly true.
You can't come in here and see the multiple dominance hierarchies that are at
work.
You can in a way,
because the chairs are set up to face this way and I'm facing that way.
That gives you some clues about the social order here and you take the cues
instantly,
right?
You come down,
you sit in the chairs,
you organize yourselves according to mutual expectation and that's part of your
procedural knowledge about how to behave as a social creature.
Now that knowledge is really,
really deep.
And a lot of it's coded in your behavior now and another people's behavior as
well.
And that's,
you know,
that's,
that's the expectations you have of other people,
end of yourself.
And a lot of those are implicit,
right?
So when we're interacting,
there's,
there's a,
there's a very large number of things that you just don't get to do.
And you know that too,
and you won't do them.
And that way we can act as if we understand each other,
even though we don't,
because you're really complicated.
And I'm really complicated and there's lots of situations where we might really
be in conflict,
but because we share a map of the culture,
the cultural expectations,
it makes part of our,
it's built right into our perception.
You will act out that set of expectations.
And so will I,
and if neither of us can do that,
even if one of us can't,
we're going to stay.
We're either going to immediately devolve into conflict or we're going to avoid
each other like the plague.
And that's exactly the right thing to do.